- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is, be authentically you.
Over to you Charlamagne Tha God.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- It's this thing called the rule of 10.
The rule of 10 is, three
people going to like it,
three people not going to like, and
four people just going to
be on the fence about it,
like they just going to
kind of remain neutral
and just wait to see what happens.
I use that whenever I,
say anything in life, or
however I approach anything
like a TV show or the
radio show for that day
or a statement I might make.
Like, three people going to
agree with it, three people not,
and four people just going
to be on the fence about it.
So, you just have to take all of that
in to consideration and that kind of
goes into something my father
told me a long time ago.
My father said, "You're never
as good as they say you are,
and you're never as
bad as the say you are."
- That's a fact.
- Personally, I just
don't care either way.
- Yeah.
- Like you know what I mean?
The only thing I got to do is
- You got to do your job
either way.
- Be authentically me.
- The only way you're going to truly win,
is if you're authentically you.
That's it, that's the only
way you're going to win,
everybody else is taken.
There's this great clip of 50 Cent
being on stage and talking about,
investments he's making and young artists
who are pitching him new records,
and how often he gets people that
sound exactly like somebody else.
People sending in their demos,
and they sound exactly like Lil Wayne.
And he says, "Yeah you sound
exactly like Lil Wayne,
that's crazy. If I heard him and I
heard you, I couldn't
tell the difference."
But the world doesn't
need another Lil Wayne.
You're never going to
make it to the big time,
if you're just a copy of somebody else.
It's why I don't worry about people
who copy my stuff and copy my channel.
Cause I'm just spending time looking
in the rear view mirror,
trying to play defense,
instead of going out and doing more.
Cause you never going to out me, me.
And I'm never going to out you, you.
And so at the beginning of your journey,
it's okay to copy, at the beginning.
Because you're getting your feet wet,
you're still trying to figure out
who you are, trying to figure out
what style you can bring to it.
But somewhere along the line,
you have to figure out okay,
here's what I stand for,
here's what I want to add,
here's how I'm different and I'm not
just going to copy somebody else anymore.
The goal of this channel, is to
learn from all this famous entrepreneurs,
to help you be the best
version of you, right?
I don't need you to be the best or
next Steve Jobs or the
next Howard Schultz,
be the best you.
I want to be the best Evan Carmichael
and I'm going to put a piece from
all these people to
help me be the best me.
And I want you to do the same.
Don't try to be the next anybody,
just be the best you.
That's where you're going to win,
the people at the top are
authentically themselves.
They may have learned
lessons from other people,
they may have collaborated
with other people,
they may have asked
opinions of other people,
but at the end of the day, they're doing
the thing that is unique to them,
they are injecting their art
into what they are making,
and if you don't do that,
you're always going to
place second, third,
you're always going to be
way down on the list.
It takes a lot of guts,
it takes a lot of courage
to be authentically you.
And it comes from doing it with practice.
The more you do it, the
more you take a stance,
the more you try to inject
a little bit onto something,
the more you're going to start to win.
The more it's going to feel right,
the more you're going to get
people onboard with your crusade.
That's where you're really going to win,
so start being authentically you.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
what have you added recently into your
business that is authentically you?
You added your mark onto it,
what did you do that was different?
Leave it down in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Randy Wilson,
Randy thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, "You're One Word".
Really really means a lot to me man
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot, of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- How did you come up in radio, how'd you
start with radio?
- I started off as an intern in 1998
when I was 18 years
old, I mean I'm 32 now.
I've been doing radio for, this will
be my 15th year in radio.
I started off as an intern when I was 18,
so I've worked in every aspect of radio.
I've worked in the promotion department,
I worked in programming, I was an intern
for a year and a half.
This is the seventh radio
station I've worked at,
I've been fired four times.
- It hurts.
- You know what I'm saying?
That's why when I saw
William, when William
came back out there to perform, well
for everybody who wasn't at the show,
William was a rapper who got booed,
well he forced them to
let him perform again.
I just like
the determination.
- Right.
- Like the never say quit attitude,
cause that's what you
have to have cause man,
like I said, I've been fired four times
I could have quit along
time ago, but I don't
have no backup plan, I
didn't go to college,
I don't have a degree.
I don't have anything
else to do but radio.
And I use to want to rap, until I realized
that rap was a pipe dream.
It's just, it's so many things that you
go through in this game
man, so many ebbs and flows,
so many ups and downs,
but it's the people that
truly keep going that make it.
But the reason I made it is because I knew
exactly what I wanted to do.
- Tell me what your
vision board looks like,
and can you share some of
the things that are on there?
- I use to have a traditional vision board
where you know you would
take things that you want
and put them up on poster board.
That's cool, I did that
when I did, "The Secret".
But to me, the best vision boards are when
you write down your long
term, short term goals.
Write down everything that
you want to accomplish,
and keep those things
in your mind because,
you mind is what makes the manifest
and the reality, like
your thoughts really do
become things like, I don't
have a collage degree,
or anything like that, all I have is
back in 1998 I said, I
want to be a super jock.
I said I want to be one of the biggest
radio personalities on the planet.
I said I want to be,
in that Wendy Williams,
Tom Joyner, Doug Banks,
Howard Stern, you know Bill
O'Reilly, Rush Limbaugh,
I want to be in that number.
You know, when they think of Charlamagne
I want them to think of me like that.
I want to be my generation's that.
Because all of those guys, it the natural
course of thing that power
eventually fades and weakens.
It's just like the NBA or music,
it was Magic Johnson, Larry Bryd era,
and it was the Michael Jordon era,
now the Lebron James era,
that's just the way things are in the game
and I knew that eventually
it would be my time
if I wanted that and so I claimed it.
So my vision board is
really just a notebook
with everything that I want in my life.
People move on, they're dope I mean,
50 actually put out some great records
earlier this year.
Joint he had with Kendrick Lamar,
then he had another record,
the joint with Too Short
I thought was dope.
But when people are off
you, they're off you.
I mean he got his pocket of fans that are
still support him, but you'll never see
50 Cents selling 10 million records again.
Hell you never see 50 Cent
sell a million records again.
Not of one album, he
might do it as a single,
and that's not a diss to him, it's just
- [Cameraman] Just the way Hip Hop is.
- That's the way Hip Hop is,
- Yeah
- nobody cares no more
- (mumbling)
- you know what I'm saying,
like, a thug changes, love changes,
and best friends become strangers man.
Like it happens all the
time, it happens in cycles.
Everybody can't be Jay-Z.
And the reason Jay-Z is Jay-Z cause
Jay-Z has been consistent,
Jay-Z dropped an album
every year since 1996.